every year sciences reporters and
editors
choose nine runners-up and one
breakthrough of the year but before we
get to the breakthrough
here are a few of the runners up
fast radio bursts short powerful flashes
of radio waves from distant galaxies
have tantalized astronomers for 13 years
now cosmic detectives have figured out
where they come from
magnetars neutron stars that
fizzle and pop with powerful magnetic
fields
in april an frb went off in the milky
way
researchers quickly narrowed the source
to a small area of sky
and using powerful telescopes they
quickly linked it to a single magnetar
stay tuned for a sequel as researchers
try to understand exactly how the
magnetars produce these radio bursts
since the revolutionary gene editing
tool
known as crispr burst onto the scene in
2012
it's given researchers new power to
engineer crops and animals
stirred ethical debates and earned a
nobel prize
now it scored its first victory in a
clinical trial
it helped patients with two inherited
blood diseases
beta thalassemia where low levels of an
oxygen carrying protein
called hemoglobin lead to weakness and
exhaustion
and sickle cell disease caused by a
defective form of the same protein
to treat sickle cell disease researchers
used crispr
to make the body produce the fetal form
of hemoglobin
but the crispr approach could cost one
million dollars
or more per patient putting it out of
reach for many
their eyes are beaty and their brains no
bigger than a walnut
but two studies published this year
suggest birds
have amazing mental powers scientists
took a closer look at the forebrain of
homing pigeons and owls
and found nerves there that connect
horizontally
and vertically this is similar to the
matrix of connections
seen in the human neocortex the source
of our
occasionally incredible intelligence
another study suggested that carrion
crows
already well known for their brains are
aware
of what they see and do this could mean
that some form of consciousness was
present
in our last common ancestor 320
million years ago
more than 40 000 years ago on the
indonesian island of sulawesi a
prehistoric picasso
ventured deep into a cave and sketched a
series of fantastic
animal-headed hunters cornering wild
hogs and buffalos
it's possible that the artist was
depicting the hunters
wearing masks or camouflage but they may
also
represent mythical animal human hybrids
which appear in other ancient works of
art
the age of the paintings makes them the
earliest known
figurative art made by modern humans
and now the breakthrough of the year
not one not two but
multiple vaccines have
now succeeded in large human clinical
trials
a mere 11 months after the first
sequencing of sars cov2
vaccines have already been deployed in
the uae the united kingdom
and now the united states the two
vaccines at the forefront of this wave
which use messenger rna to carry the
genetic code for the coronavirus spike
protein
reported an amazing efficacy roughly
95 but other approaches
like using inactivated cold viruses to
shuttle the spike protein
or harmless versions of the virus itself
could
also soon make their way to market
never before have so many competitors
collaborated
so openly and never before have
governments
businesses and institutions all around
the world
poured this much money and manpower
into the hunt for a vaccine
but even as this research has yielded
remarkable results
the pandemic also marks a breakdown in
communication
public trust and a sense of shared
reality
that has transformed the deadly threat
of coven 19
into something far worse
as of mid-december more than 1.6 million
people
have died globally of complications from
coven 19
with more than 300 000 deaths in the
united states alone
science has delivered an exit strategy
through effective vaccines but human
behavior has been
and continues to be the most important
variable
in shaping our path forward
[Music]